So, ich bin wieder da.
Es kann sein, dass ich gleich nochmal kurz weg muss
für 5 Minuten.
Wahrscheinlich 5 Minuten sogar zu lang.
Für ein paar Minuten.
Ich muss der Katze noch Medizin
abreichen.
PHP.
Da gucke ich nicht. Bei mir ist es ewig her.
Das letzte, was ich mit
PHP gemacht habe, ist zu
Battlefield 4 Zeiten so eine Profilpage.
Für Leute, die auf meinem
Server gespielt haben.
Und wann war
Battlefield 4? 2012 oder so?
Ja.
Aber nichts Wildes.
Die hat Schilddrüsen-Probleme.
Da muss die
immer...
Da braucht die so...
Das muss man in so eine Spritze aufziehen.
Das ist so Süßkram.
Und da muss man ihr dann...
Also Spritze nicht zum Spritzen, sondern
zum Ablecken.
Und da muss man die
auf den Arm nehmen und die Spritze in den Mund schieben.
Und das ihr dann verabreichen.
Aber glücklicherweise...
Schmeckt das nicht so schlimm.
Und die nimmt das ganz gut.
Ja, also...
Oh Leute, irgendwie bin ich ein bisschen müde.
Ich weiß auch nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Zu viel rumgegammelt heute den ganzen Tag.
Ich muss erstmal ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen aufwachen irgendwie.
Ich hab nicht eben gepennt oder so.
Aber keine Ahnung.
Alles ein bisschen...
Wahrscheinlich ist es zu warm.
Den Klimaanlage an.
Ne, ne, ne.
Machen wir nicht.
Prog.
Danke für den Sub.
Nice.
Ich schmeiß schon mal meine VM an.
Gut, dass wir heute Morgen schon alles geupdatet haben.
Also, das machen wir auch manchmal, aber selten heute nicht.
Heute gucken wir uns PHP an.
Ich hab ewig nix mit PHP gemacht.
Und zwar gucken wir uns heute...
...das da an.
Wie gesagt, es wird nix super krass kompliziertes.
Wir machen ein Webservice, der KekW...
...das KekW...
...Bild rotiert.
Fertig.
KekWS.
Irgendwie kann Google...
...findet das nicht.
Ja, ich kann hier...
...Woblords GitHub machen.
Aber irgendwie findet das...
...findet das Google nicht.
Weiß auch nicht.
Ja, ich hab sowas für...
...vor Ewigkeiten schon mal gebaut in C Sharp.
Das ist eigentlich so ein...
...gleich mit Zwell...
...Nein, wir machen kein wirkliches Frontend.
Wir machen ein paar API-Routen.
Und ich guck, wie man Parameter übergeben kann.
Weil das ist heute tatsächlich mal ausnahmsweise was,
wo ich im Vorfeld gar nichts,
wirklich gar nichts geguckt hab.
Und auch keine Ahnung von hab.
Ja.
Also das ist so ne Testanwendung,
die ich für alle möglichen Sachen immer mal verwende.
Die haben wir beispielsweise auch immer benutzt,
um irgendwelche Cloud-Services...
...das Hosting von irgendwelchen Cloud-Services ausprobieren.
Die kann nichts, ja.
Die hat zwei Routen.
Einmal halt die...
...Rout...
...Route.
Da wird ein Bild random gedreht.
Um 360 Grad.
Dann gibt es ne Route...
...wo man ein Parameter mitgeben kann.
Äh...
Ne, einmal hier kann man ein Parameter-Kit mitgeben.
Und hier gibt es das...
Hä?
...Kit geko...
Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich hier überhaupt gemacht hab.
Ach so!
Das eine ist...
Ah.
Nee.
Das ist doch genau das Gleiche hier, oder?
Keine Ahnung, warum es das zweimal gibt.
Kein Schimmer.
So was bauen wir.
Das rufst du auf, dann sagst du
slash keg w und kriegst ein Bild gedreht.
Ja.
Und ich glaube, das reicht mir schon mal heute,
so was in PHP zu bauen,
weil ich keine Ahnung von...
Okay, guck mal.
Das ist das PHP-Framework für Web Artists...
Was ist denn das überhaupt?
Ein Artist oder wie?
Oder...
Weißte...
Was ist das?
Deutsch?
Handwerker!
Das ist ja ne...
Ich glaube, das haben sie sich früher auch schon so genannt.
Richtig agile Handwerker.
So.
Und das Ding ist, ich muss erst mal gucken, wie man das installiert.
Ja.
Vielleicht mach ich demnächst auch was mit Holz.
Man weiß ja nie.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir nur gucken, wie man das überhaupt installiert.
Ich hab...
Ich hab wirklich, legit...
Ich hab absolut keinen Plan.
Guck mal mal.
Vielleicht gibt's hier schon was im Auer...
Im Arsch.
By the way.
Nee.
...gibt es nicht.
Cake PHP.
Ich weiß, ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist.
Cake PHP versus Laravel.
Okay.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das einzige PHP-Framework,
mit dem ich jemals was gemacht habe,
ist Laravel.
Deswegen machen wir das damit jetzt auch.
Laravel muss über Composer ein npm für PHP...
Oh ja.
wird immer besser alter da ist endlich ich habe npm reicht noch nicht jetzt brauchen wir noch
npm für php habe ich gucken uns das gleich mal an so also doch getting started on linux ich
brauche keinen docker dafür sail ab wort für die pläne und linux und docker kompost you can use a
simple terminal command to create new level voll warum brauche ich zum teufel aber warum brauche
ich docker warum brauche ich doch dafür okay wir gucken mal kurz rein was da drin ist a docker
stellt ok docker docker pull level new nein ich will einfach den kram installieren choosing your
sales service machen was mein was was wollt ihr von mir überhaupt
gibt sich irgendwie so was wie how to install ist es geil dass in der gesamten installations
anpackung dass das in der gesamten installation anleitung nein die machen ab moment hier ist es
doch hier ist es doch okay ich habe nichts gesagt hier hier ist es doch composer braucht man okay
jetzt kommt ich mache leute ich mach mal ein snapshot vielleicht muss ich den ganzen php
composer composer composer da sind wir doch ein dependency manager for php jawoll let's go endlich
php stellt wie 1995 auf geht's gehen wir mal in meinen temp ordner mkdir php keckel ok also wie
geht das jetzt composer create projects laravel slash laravel ok warum auch immer komposer create projects laravel slash laravel ok warum auch immer komposer create projects laravel slash laravel ok warum auch immer
gut moment after u f intel habe ich überhaupt prp installiert ja aber ich weiß warum habe ich
php installiert weil composer php mitbringt okay after uf install prp and composer the make rate
Johan or you may create e olmay project park globally install ins globalize das ist quasi das ist so was
wahnsinnig groß ist pod yourself ich habe da eine tempelage in osn одну lage lokale oder설 als sowas wie npx und das ist so was wie npmf sticker tali nach妬
install und dann und dann danach ausführen okay das geht das geht auch so
hat er nur dankeschön ich habe aber hier schon was ich trinkzeug example app heck
wie es service in php nice wie bei javascript das halbe internet wird
runtergeladen das ging aber schnell also also für javascript verhältnis ist das
gar nicht mal so viel glaube ich schaue mal 64 mb da lacht sich ja jede java
skript anwendung darüber kaputt leute wir haben letztens welt kit anwendung
gemacht moment zelt kit anwendung copy pasta
champ demo soll das zum vergleich eines welt kit anwendung
der demos welt kit anwendung ist einfach 500 mb kurs javascript
keck javascript wahrscheinlich die ganzen logos aus der lippe ich vermute ich vermute ich vermute ich vermute ich vermute ich vermute ich vermute ich vermute
nordmann jules ordner okay temp
okay wie jetzt wie geht es weiter auch leute wir brauchen es erstmal moment
moment hat haben die nicht php champion nicht was für php das brauchen wir jetzt
webstorm php storm warum sollte ich warum sollte ich eigentlich php storm anstelle
warum gibt es überhaupt zwei ach so dass eine ist die javascript ide und das andere ist die php ichollar
die php storm das will schon ich komme als wert sich schon es widersetzt sich
es will kein php machen gibt so was wie php web assembly oder mist ich habe
nicht nachgeguckt aber wahrscheinlich ja natürlich php im browser jawoll da habe
ich mein ganzes leben lang darauf gewartet endlich kann ich php
kleinseitig verwenden ich kann kleinseitige anwendungen php machen
weiß endlich ok php storm da haben wir es so als aber erst mal kurz gucken wie
geht es denn hier weiter keck ws service es okay eine sache ist schon mal eine
sache haben sie schon mal sehr javascript mäßig sich abgeguckt denn man
hat erst mal eine sache die man sich schon mal sehr javascript mäßig sich
erstmal hunderttausend dinger wie konflikt hat man hat der fuck was ist
hier alles nikki c ist auch am start tests die
kennen mich aber schlecht die haben standardmäßig schon tests
dabei was ist denn hier alles dabei da blickt doch keiner durch channel
was ist denn hier alles dabei da blickt doch keiner durch channel was ist denn hier alles dabei da blickt doch keiner durch channel
ірke
council in spaya what okay das ist ein demoanwendung gibt es auch ne nackige
capsule in spaya what okay das ist ein demo anwendung gibt es auch ne nackige
competitor helikoptergasp her Official AiResArt
idk hier was als pdf ich wünscht mir aber an ein fenex Account, Port вас nach einem
systems
da ist er heute das ist die level demo anwendung ja jetzt weiß ich auch warum
der javascript zeug dabei ist weil die ein bisschen frontend geduld haben aber
ich will ich will ja eigentlich nur ein api projekt machen gibt es gibt es so
ein mini mini projekt was lerner will was ries
authentification features nein das ist ja noch mehr ich will auch kein login
dafür haben nachts gab es nicht es gab heute chat
geht nur weil ich 90 prozent samstag immer luden mit lachs futter es jeden
haben zwei minuten mittags heute habe ich kann euch sagen was gefördert habe
ich habe reis gefüttert mit so vielleicht flying goose hot sauce und
dann 33 waffel mit blaubeeren drauf richtig gesund
ja
beste ist das flying goose hot sauce wie das ist irgendwas anderes leute das
das ist gut was ist hier unten los jetzt okay das ist unsere level demo
anwendung jetzt muss ich erstmal alles wir machen das jetzt mal in php storm
auf php php storm premiere noch nie hatte ich php storm auf
auf php php php php php php php php php php php php php php php php php php php
php php php php php.
aber das gute ist ich habe versus all inclusive desktop package prime stop
klassen wird Fisher's li 시e bak das geht ja schon mal gut los,
es wird struffen so hat sogar einen reminder drinne, dass jeder will spaß kann am movie ins
Install? Nein, nein, nein.
Ah! Was macht es?
Was macht es im Hintergrund?
Composer? Revert?
Ich klicke
das einfach mal alles zu.
Download, pre-build,
shared indexes. Ja, wunderbar.
Was auch immer. App.
Kernel.
Alter, was ist
das alles? Ich will eine Hello World Anwendung.
Was zum
Was ist? Ne.
Das, das wieder, das, das, ne.
Okay, das. Ich bilde mir auch ein.
Ich habe, wie gesagt, vor Jahren was in Laravel gemacht.
Das war gar nicht so wild.
Da hast du drei Dateien gebraucht
und gut ist. Wann war BF4
Release Date?
Ja, ja, so 2014
habe ich was mit Laravel gemacht. Das war eigentlich total easy.
Aber
das sah nicht, das sah nicht so krass
kompliziert aus wie hier.
Warte. Artisan
PHP. Was?
Okay, als erstes, Leute, ihr kennt mich. Als erstes
müssen wir erst einmal
Font einstellen.
Font Size.
Ich bin noch nicht mal
in der Lage,
überhaupt zu finden.
Hier, Font.
JetBrains
Mono. Nein, nein, nein. Hack.
18.
Ja, schon viel besser.
So, und wo stellt man
den PHP-Storm
jetzt das neue UI ein,
dass es halbwegs gescheit aussieht?
Color Scheme.
Haben wir einen Rider-Color-Scheme?
Irgendwas, was gescheit aussieht?
Dark.
Ja, okay, schon besser.
Was?
Appearance.
Nothing here. Okay.
Oh, was ist?
What the?
Was? Don't show?
What?
Okay.
Nothing here.
Theme.
Oh, mein Auge.
Nee, das Material-Theme mag ich nicht.
Ähm.
Wo? Appearance?
Nee, wo ist denn der Mist jetzt?
Appearance.
Hier, hä?
Wo macht man das neue UI jetzt?
Da kann man das UI wechseln.
Ja.
Aber wo?
Ach, new UI.
Hier, enable.
Ja.
Okay, gut. Restart.
Dann sieht das wirklich besser.
Wie sieht dieser aus?
Kurz trinken.
Meet a new UI.
Ja, das ist doch schon gleich viel nicer.
Oh.
System. Dark. Clean. Compact.
Naja.
In der Breite.
Wie macht man das überhaupt zu?
Okay, schon mal viel
angenehmer.
Ernsthaft, Leute, was sehe ich hier überhaupt?
Config.
Mail.
Was ist denn hier los?
Ich will keine Mails verschicken, ich will einfach nur eine API, zwei API-Endpunkte haben.
Yondi-Boy schreibt, nee, Yonder-Boy schreibt was, ach.
Ich wünschte, ich könnte auch Jetprints bei mir auf der Arbeit fänden, haben wir nicht mal ein Git insofern.
Äh, warum kannst du es nicht verwenden?
Weil, weil die es nicht kaufen wollen, oder was?
Oder weil du nichts installieren darfst.
Der Realist Battery Included.
Das ist ja schön, wenn Batteries included sind, aber warum gibt es für jede Batterie...
...ein eigenes File?
Leute, ich glaube, wir brauchen ein anderes PHP-Framework.
Ich will einfach nur drei API-Endpunkte haben, fertig.
Und ich dachte, das ist mit Laravel easy, weil ich habe vor zig Jahren mal was mit Laravel gemacht.
Auth.
Sanctum.
User.
Ich verstehe absolut nicht, was hier überhaupt vor sich geht.
Und nein, wir machen kein RAW-PHP.
Channels.
Console.
Ich habe echt keinen, ich habe wirklich absolut keinen Schimmer, was hier abgeht.
Okay, das ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu...
...zu oversized für meinen Zweck.
Hm.
Ich wüsste noch nicht mal, wie ich API-Endpunkte mache.
Unter Roots kannst du, kannst du, aber hier, API-PAP.
Hier ist, wo du API-Routes für deine App registrieren kannst.
Diese Routen sind erlaubt bei...
Okay, probieren wir das.
Probieren wir das mal.
Route.
Middleware.
Auth.
Leute, ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Get.
Kek.
W.
Function.
Request.
Return.
User.
Lull.
So.
Jetzt führen wir das aus.
Und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert, wenn ich auf die Route slash Kek W gehe.
Not found.
Middleware muss ich wegmachen?
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, ich muss ein Tutorial lesen, erstmal.
Get not found.
Und jetzt hier einfach...
Was? Slash API, Slash KQ?
Wie gesagt, ich habe zuletzt was mit Laravel 2014 gemacht.
Da war das total easy, Routen und Sachen anzulegen.
Ach so, im Browser.
Also quasi, API, Slash KQ.
Ah, guck mal da.
Root Login not defined.
Okay, Leute, ich glaube, Laravel ist wirklich für unseren Use Case echt krass oversized.
Laravel Simple Root.
Laravel Create New Application.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Was haben wir eigentlich gemacht?
Create Project.
Ne, wir haben nur Create Project gemacht, sonst nix.
Das ist noch Laravel 4.
Ein PHP Framework.
How to create Roots in Laravel.
Easy, okay.
Zeig mal hier, easy.
Root, aha, okay, das ist tatsächlich relativ easy.
Ich will kein View return.
Ich will einfach...
Raw Data return.
Okay.
Get return.
Ich will keinen View return.
Kann ich einfach irgendeinen String returnen oder sowas?
API, Slash KQ.
Oder, ne, ne, nur KQ.
Surf.
Installing Loom.
Was zum Teufel ist denn jetzt Loomen schon wieder?
Ich sehe...
Loomen.
Auf jeden Fall eine Seite ohne Dark Mode.
Ich würde gerne mal wissen, was Loomen überhaupt ist.
Wird nicht verraten.
Loomen has a few...
Ja, ja, und was ist das?
Okay.
Loomen.
Aha, Loomen ist quasi so eine...
So eine lightweight Laravel-Geschichte von Laravel.
Aber ist deprecated.
Ernsthaft?
Warum ist Loomen deprecated?
Okay, ja, das sollten wir schon mal nicht verwenden.
Aber ich wollte ja mal gucken.
Jetzt sollte es ja eigentlich eine KQW-Route geben.
Ach, ne, Moment.
API-KQW.
Jawoll!
Easy!
Haben wir doch schon.
Easy.
Easy as fuck!
Ich würde sagen, dann, oder?
Für heute.
Nice!
Ne, der Witz ist doch, dass ich was mit PHP machen will.
Wenn ich was mit irgendeiner anderen Sprache...
Das ist ja...
Macht ja keinen Sinn.
Ich würde sagen, dann...
Auf geht's, ja.
Senior PHP-Developer.
Okay, das habe ich an der Stelle jetzt gecheckt, wie man Routen anlegt.
Die Frage ist, kann ich den ganzen anderen Cample löschen?
Ich brauche keine...
Okay, Controller brauche ich.
Storage brauche ich nicht.
Keine Tests.
Das ist quasi meine Node-Modules, würde ich sagen.
Ich vermute aber, wenn ich die Ordner einfach lösche,
dann ist es broken.
Und was ist der App-Ordner?
App-Service-Provider?
Root-Service-Provider?
Slash...
Slash-Home?
What?
Okay, gut, das ist definiert.
Das ist geil.
Console-Kernel-PHP.
Also, Laravel macht mich echt verrückt.
Also, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich habe das 2014 mal verwendet.
Und da war das eigentlich relativ easy, dort Sachen drin anzulegen.
Aber das ist wirklich äußerst...
Ich meine, es geht.
Wenn man sich das mal anguckt, das ist ein bisschen was wie Ruby on Rails.
So ein bisschen ähnlich wie Ruby on Rails aufgebaut.
Rootstrap?
Ach, die App.
Singlet?
Okay, die Sprache ist aus...
Illuminate?
Okay, wir bleiben mal bei der Minimalgeschichte.
Wir bleiben mal bei der Minimalgeschichte, ja?
Wir haben eine Route-Slash-Keg-Wee.
So.
Und jetzt will ich einen...
Wie rotiere ich Bilder?
Also, okay, nee, war was anderes.
Wie gebe ich jetzt hier...
Wie mache ich hier sowas wie return-pile.open?
Nee.
Das kriege ich raus.
Also, keg-wee, wir downloaden uns jetzt erstmal das Bild.
Wobei, wir müssen uns das Bild nicht runterladen.
Ich habe das doch hier irgendwo drin.
Äh...
keg-wee-as-a-service.
W-W-W-Root.
Ach, ich habe die Dinger sogar vorberechnet.
Nee, das müssen wir besser machen.
Okay, bestes, bestes Bild.
Copy-Image.
Public.
In Public kommt das wahrscheinlich rein.
CD.
Public.
W-Get.
Äh...
Copy-Image-Link.
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf.
Image.
Image-Cut.
Zack.
Schon haben wir das in der Konsole.
Das Beste.
Wichtig und richtig.
File-Get-Contents.
Ich sehe, ich sehe, der Chat hat Ahnung.
Aber ich muss sowas selbst rauskriegen, sonst ist es ziemlich, ziemlich pepega, ja.
Und jetzt muss ich gucken, wie ich Bilder rotieren kann.
Okay, File-Get-Contents.
Ich vermute mal relativ zur Anwendung.
Slash Public.
Keg-Wee-PNG.
Ach ja, hat das Hot-Reload?
Hat das sowas?
Wie Hot-Reload?
Oh.
Oh je.
Public-Keg-Wee-PNG.
Absolut relativ?
Wie muss man das angeben?
Aber ich hab's relativ angegeben.
Es ist Public.
Sehen wir vielleicht, in welchem Verzeichnis wir sind?
PH-Prä.
Print-Current-Directory.
Get-CWD.
Alles klar.
Noch besser.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
In welchem Verzeichnis sind wir?
Ach, wir sind schon in Public.
Ach so.
Ja dann.
Ease.
Dann ist es einfach nur Keg-Wee.PNG.
Ah, da muss ich bestimmt meinem Type und sowas angeben.
Das ist ja nicht als Image, sondern als Binary-Zeug.
Wie macht man das?
File-Get.
Das sind wahrscheinlich Bytes.
Ach so, ja.
Moment.
Wie macht man Variablen?
B-A-B.
Ich bin komplett planlos.
File-Response ist exzellent, Chat.
Exzellent.
Ah, aha, okay.
Return-Response-Make.
File-Response ist Response.
Ach so, einfach so.
Return-Response-File-Path-to-File-Headers.
Okay.
Ups, was jetzt?
Das hat...
Okay, okay.
Return.
Und eine Variable ist einfach so.
Bytes.
Ja.
Okay, Return-Response-File-Pack-Wee-PNG.
Einfach so?
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
So, aber so einfach ist es nicht.
Weil, kann man hier auch Bytes...
Kann man hier auch Bytes übergeben?
Muss mal gucken.
Nein.
Response.
Ich mein, ich muss dem Ding...
Make?
Vielleicht?
Warum macht man freiwillig PHP?
Weil ich mir einfach mal wieder PHP angucken wollte.
Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn.
Die Sache ist die, ich glaube...
Also ich muss jetzt...
Also normalerweise muss man folgendes machen.
Man muss so Response anlegen.
Man muss den Mime-Type festlegen.
Also was wie Application.json.
In dem Fall ist es Image.png.
Und, ähm...
Muss ich irgendwie Header hinzufügen?
Für, für...
Wie geht das jetzt?
Json-Response ist Response.json?
New-Response.
Laravel-Response.
Content-Type, ja.
Aber das kann doch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache sein,
da ich das selbst von Hand angeben muss, oder?
Das muss doch...
Das muss doch dieses Response-Objekt garantiert schon irgendwie drinnen haben.
Make.
Für was ist Make?
Gibt es, gibt es Hilfe?
Gibt es vielleicht Hilfen für die, für diese Dinger?
Returns by...
...
äh, wie, Laravel Response Make Image PNG, wie macht man sowas, ja, Method to Use Response Stream, ach, ja, sehr schön, ne, Moment, das will ich nicht, aber ich kann auch bestimmt auch streamen, nicht vom File, sondern von einem Byte Array oder sowas,
ok, Response Stream, Response Make, und dann File 200, und dann sagt man Content Type Image PNG, ok, dann ist es tatsächlich relativ easy, also sagt man einfach so, Response Make, Return Response, oder, Moment, Make, ist das dann so, Unnecessary Local, ja, ja,
und jetzt Response Header, Content Type, muss man das großschreiben, Content Type, und ich glaube, es ist Image PNG, ich bin mir da nicht ganz, ganz sicher, ich glaube, ist es Image slash PNG, glaub, glaub schon, ok, testen wir mal, jawoll, easy,
so, und jetzt wird's kompliziert, jetzt müssen wir das Image rotieren,
irgendwie in PHP, PHP, Rotate, PNG, Image Rotate, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, wow, Image Rotate, Rotate an Image with a given angle, Eis fliegt, danke schön, danke für die anderen Saps, die ich vielleicht übersehen habe, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was ich so, na, Aufwachen ist das, ach so, hast du die, Moment, siehst du die Emotes nicht, so sollte das Emote eigentlich bei dir aussehen,
wenn du bei dir die Emotes nicht siehst, dann brauchst du FFZ, oder Better Twitch TV, oder Seven TV, Image Rotate, Image Rotate, das kann man einfach inkluden, XGD is missing, was ist, was ist XGD, ok, ich brauche Image Rotate,
How to rotate image in a Laravel application, siehste, easy guides,
Composer create, Composer require intervention, Alter, was ist das hier, 360 no scope,
was ist, was ist Intervention Image, ist das irgendeine Image Library, was anderes wie die, die, ok, was ist, was ist besser, Standard Library, oder, oder Intervention, ok,
dann machen wir das doch mal, Composer require intervention,
was, das macht ernsthaft irgendeinen Sonntagscheck, ich glaube es nicht, ok, so, jetzt ist es installiert, und weiter, Config App, oh, what, what, oh, Leute, ich muss kurz, ich muss kurz der Katze Medikamente verabreichen, ich bin, ich bin gleich wieder, ich bin gleich wieder da,
zwei Minuten,
oh,
nice, wieder am Start,
heute hat es sich gewehrt, die wollte ihr Zeug nicht futtern,
alles klar, hier steht, wie man das, wie man das macht, ok,
Basic, Basic, Image make, Open an Image,
Also, sprich, Image make,
gucken, ob das meine, mein,
PHP-Gremple hier,
Undefined Class Image,
wahrscheinlich,
muss ich das noch irgendwie in Laravel,
integrieren,
This library requires at least, and comes with,
Read about Laravel integration, ok,
After you have installed image,
open your Laravel config file,
add the following lines,
in the providers array,
ok, machen wir,
ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da mache,
aber ich mache das jetzt einfach mal,
im providers,
im providers array,
das da hinzufügen,
Intervention, 360, no scope, alles klar,
and the facade of this, in the alias array,
ich habe keine, ich habe wirklich absolut keine Ahnung, was ich da mache, aber ok,
achso, ich habe es gar nicht gestartet,
so, und jetzt, und jetzt, kann man Image verwenden,
ja, das habe ich ja gerade gemacht,
ne, das braucht, da stand doch, dass ich das nicht brauche,
Import the Image Manager Class,
aber ich habe immer noch kein Image,
jetzt ist die, gd-library-extension not available with this php-installation,
also jetzt brauche ich, php, gd,
alles klar, easy,
einfach nachinstallieren, so, next,
gd-library-extension not available with this php-installation,
no, god,
alter,
ok,
was, php-gd,
ist eine Extension, die in der php-ini sein muss,
wie jetzt,
ich habe das schon installiert eben,
guck,
php-ini,
was,
wo ist denn meine php-ini,
ach, das kann es doch nicht sein, das muss auch ohne,
in etc,
etc,
Moment, ich muss, ich muss für eine,
zum Anwendungsentwickeln,
in einem Verzeichnis, wo ich eine Root-Rechte habe, rumwursten,
Webserver, ich bin, ich habe keinen Webserver laufen,
ich habe den Standard eingebauten Webserver,
ne, ne, ne, ne, das muss anders gehen,
wo, wo, wo, wo aktiviert man das,
artisan-serve-php-gd,
ich muss wirklich in etc was machen, ja,
und jetzt,
ja,
so,
und jetzt, und jetzt,
serve,
image-source-not-readable,
ok, ok, wir kommen der Sache näher,
wir kommen der Sache näher,
man kann hier nicht standardmäßig einen auskommentieren,
mit dem Standard-Shortcut,
was ist denn das,
ok, kek-w, kek,
kek-w-png,
gucken wir mal, ob das, ob das funktioniert,
so, header-content-type-image,
ne, das wird wahrscheinlich so nicht funktionieren, oder,
irgendwie Bytes oder, anymore, dollar-image?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Image.
Wie greif ich denn jetzt da auf irgendwelche Sachen zu?
Aber warum, warum hab ich einen ?
Aus-Complete dafür jetzt, was ist denn das?
Undefined-class, stimmt doch überhaupt nicht,
muss ich das reloaden?
Weg damit,
php-Storm nochmal neu aufmachen.
File,
Open Beyonce,
checkt ich mache das jetzt noch mal neu auf tmp php das window import class intervention
image so muss man das machen non static method make should not be called statically aber das
sagt die doku selbst dass man das machen soll make aha und jetzt beiz irgendwie gibt es gibt
es dabei von oder kann man oder kann man das jetzt einfach hier hin hier rein schieben anscheinend
wie auch immer das jetzt die typ konvertierung macht keine ahnung call to undefined method
warum ist das undefined undefined method welche make
aber aber moment die sagen doch selbst dass es so geht ach nee moment konfiguriert favorit
image driver bei default image make mache ich doch war ich mache ich doch new image
ich hab's doch keine ahnung was ich hier überhaupt machen integration level ja das mache ich doch
example ja angeblich soll das einfach funktionieren ohne irgendwas guck hier was ist das bei default
intervention images if you want to switch schnell ich muss gar nichts angeblich muss ich nur also
integration level is easy as fuck man muss man muss diese zwei sachen hinzufügen und das war's
mehr muss man mehr muss man nicht machen
tales with mists
sagt sagt das geht aber nicht aber ich hab mir schon alles importiert was man importieren muss cooks import
intervention image aber fall shimport ist das richtig ich habe sie ja auch wenn er muss man erst ein料e mit ja
gut Kerclsиков PNG They tell me a little art wird eh okay so legends playовые computer Lese also falls від
Response vom...
Das solltest du doch eigentlich selbst wissen, oder?
Da ist es!
Nice!
Es hat funktioniert.
Und es hat vorher resized.
Okay, easy, easy.
Hat funktioniert. Okay, rotate.
Image, rotate.
Um, keine Ahnung,
40 Grad. So.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
So,
KW ist rotated.
Und jetzt die Frage,
random in PHP.
Random PHP.
Rand. Rand in...
Was ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied?
Rand?
Okay, random in
versus Rand.
S-P-R-B-R-A-N-D-O-M-I-N-D-P-R-A-N-D-I-C-H-I-L-L-Y-C-U-E.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Ja, das ist mir egal,
ob das cryptographically secure ist.
Okay, Rand.
Min.
Okay, von
0 bis 360.
Nee, von 1 bis 360,
weil, ist das inclusive
oder exclusive?
If called min arguments,
inclusive.
Okay, also brauche ich
brauche ich 1
und 360 Grad.
Okay, war...
Nee, nee, nee, Moment.
Äh, hier, i.
Bester, besser Name überhaupt, i.
Jetzt, okay.
Einmal, einmal eine random Nummer
rotaten um Dollar i, please.
Ha, es funktioniert, Leute.
Random rotation ist am Start.
KW as a service
alive.
Oh.
Was ist jetzt?
Habe ich mich jetzt gebannt?
Man kann sich mit local host requests bannen.
Wirklich, ja.
Und wie entbanne ich mich wieder?
Fixing too many requests.
Hier, middleware groups.
If you open a PHP...
Kernel PHP. Okay, okay, okay, Moment.
App.
Äh.
Äh, nee.
Wo muss ich hin?
Ab hatte, war doch richtig.
Ab PHP, kernel PHP.
Was kann ich denn?
Kernel?
Middleware groups,
API und was?
Throttle.
Hier.
Äh.
Wie jetzt?
Middleware groups.
Middleware groups, ja.
You will see throttle API.
Nö.
Sehe ich nicht.
Aber wir wissen jetzt zumindest mal wie das heißt.
Redis. Redis?
Was?
Nee nee, das ist es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Da sind irgendwelche options hintendran.
60 und eins.
Nee oder?
Da muss ich doch nicht hinten angeben oder?
Doch?
Muss ich da irgendwas hinten?
Ich weiß ernsthaft nicht wie das geht.
Okay,ahoven,
10,
Throttle
Vielleicht kann man das
Genau, vielleicht kann man es einfach auskommentieren
Das ist natürlich auch noch eine Idee
Easy
Einfach das Throttling auskommentieren
Wer braucht denn sowas auch schon
Also PHP ist wirklich so
Nicht meine erste Wahl, was
Websachen angeht für Klinik
Der Vorteil ist halt
Es läuft überall
Okay, jetzt werde ich auch nicht mehr
Gethrottled
Python läuft auch überall, nö
Mietet dir mal
Ein billiges
Webhosting und versuch da mal
Python laufen zu lassen, kannst vergessen
Du kannst
Vielleicht mit Python
Static Site Generator machen oder so
Aber sicherlich nicht
Das da drauf laufen
Lassen
Also ansonsten sind wir nicht mehr gethrottled
Sehr schön, hätten wir das schon mal
So, okay und jetzt kommt
Als nächstes ein Parameter
Ja, naja, ne, ne, ne, Auflösung
Nicht unbedingt, Parameter brauchen wir
Wir brauchen noch ein Parameter für
Also, das ist jetzt ja random
Random
Wie das rotiert wird
Was wir jetzt noch brauchen ist
Wir brauchen nicht
Random Rotated, sondern
Wir brauchen die gleiche Sache
Nochmal
Wobei, ne, wie mach ich denn hier
Wie mach ich denn hier Parameter
Also in C Sharp würde ich jetzt irgendwie vielleicht sowas
Probieren, aber okay
Laravel, Root, Get
Parameter
Root Parameter
Ach, siehste mal
Ich lag gar nicht so verkehrt
Machen wir mal wirklich sowas hier
Äh, ID ist es ja nicht
Wirklich
Ne, ich glaub wir brauchen wirklich zwei Routen, ne
Ich glaub wir brauchen einmal so eine
Und dann brauchen wir
Noch eine für
Ähm, Angle
Oder
Rotation
Und wie greif ich da jetzt drauf zu
Ah, Function
String ID
Function, und hier machen wir jetzt
Int
Ne, das ist falsch
Dollar, Dollar Angle
Okay, dann machen wir
Nämlich den Random Shit raus
So, das müsste
Jetzt eigentlich schon gehen, passt mal auf
Keck, 1, das funktioniert
Punst
Easy, 340
Na gut, wir sollten noch mal
Wir sollten uns noch mal ein bisschen was angucken
Ich mein, eigentlich ist es egal, ne
Der rotatet ja dann einfach weiter
Aber wir könnten mal gucken, wie man eine Exception wirft
Oder einen Error Code wirft
Mit PHP
If
Angle
Schau mal, ähm, größer
Äh, sag mal, oder
Angle
Kleiner 1
Dann, Return
Response
So, wie macht man jetzt hier
Wie macht man hier einen Error
Code
Oder kann man hier einfach
Den Code übergeben
Ach, hier kann man einfach sagen, Status, ne
Hecke
Status Code
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es
HTTP 900 gibt
Status Code 900
Ist not valid
Hahahaha
HTTP 900
Gibt's das überhaupt
Moment
Tatsächlich
413, ja beste
Ähm, 418
Wie jetzt
Content ist Kackel
Ja, ok, es funktioniert halbwegs, ja
Also, wenn man Mist angibt, so zum Beispiel 0 oder sowas
Dann geht's nicht
Wenn man ordentlich ein Angle angibt, dann klappt das
Irgendwie 90
90, 180
Ja, mal gucken, wie das mit Punkten ist
Ich glaube nicht, dass das so unescaped
Moment, das geht
Aber das ist ein Int
Warum kann ich Kommas in Ints machen
Ach, der schneidet einfach den hinteren Teil ab, hä
Passt mal auf
Warum sollte man das eigentlich nur Ints machen
Das wird jetzt einfach nur ein Float
Easy
Ändert sich da was
Weiß nicht
So, und jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch mal was checken
Wie macht man ein Console
Äh, Console out PHP
How to log to Console in PHP
Ja, ja, ja
Nein, nicht die Console
Nein
Nein, nein, nein, nein
Ja
Serverseitig
Impload
Debug to Console
Was?
Nein
PHP hat keine Konsole, Max?
Wieso, hier ist doch eindeutig was
PHP log string
Jetzt musst du
Nein
PHP
Error log
Ne
How to print the debug log
Boah, was?
Error log standout
Logging to standout
Log, use files
Jetzt ernsthaft, du kannst nicht einfach Konsolenausgaben in PHP so ohne weiteres machen
Delaraville, log alert
Ok, log
Ne, geht nicht
Ah, das muss ich erstmal importieren, hä
Muss ich erstmal importieren
Import, glas, jawohl
Äh
Ne, das ist das Falsche was ich importiert hab
Das gibt es nicht
das ist richtig das ist aber doch die image library warum sollte ich mit der image library
loggen ach nee intervention ist die image library illuminate ist laravel alert okay kek wait message
okay gibt er jetzt was aus? nö der gibt nichts aus moment schreibt er jetzt etwa log files und
wo schreibt er die log files hin storage logs ich will das einfach öffnen wie sag mal ist das
man muss doch man muss doch in laravel log auf die konsole rausschreiben können du suchst dump
ok dump suche ich das bin ich mir nicht sicher suche ich wahrscheinlich nicht also jetzt mal
ernsthaft laravel log send it out
das muss doch funktionieren laravel logging to standard aus
es ist doch jetzt nicht euer ernst ich mein
konsole right line php ist legacy as fuck das stimmt überhaupt nicht laravel und php wird
weiterhin aktiv entwickelt das ist so wie wir im kommentar schicken
Wenn du sagen würdest, T++ ist Legacy,
ist Fuck. Wobei...
Echo?
Okay, was? Print?
F? Okay, ihr seid's.
Chat? Excellent.
Lull.
Nö.
Jetzt ist es sogar kaputt.
Print F hat es zerstört.
Sag mal, es muss doch möglich sein.
System Echo.
Nee, oder?
Es muss doch möglich sein.
Es muss doch...
Log use files...
Okay, dann probieren wir das mal so, wie der Typ das hier macht.
Und jetzt...
Uses files. Was macht das?
Uses files is not found.
Ja, super. Nice.
So ist das Application Terminal.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
To edit...
You can also copy the standard R-Item
from config logging.
Okay, config logging
standard
error. Aha.
Standard out.
Aber das will ich doch gar nicht.
Das will ich doch gar nicht.
Ich will nicht alles.
Ich will einfach nur ein
Console-WriteLine machen.
Das kann doch nicht sein, dass ich
in PHP kein normales Console-WriteLine...
Also, ich meine nicht im Browser.
PHP
print standard out.
So.
Was?
Nee, standard out.
Output.
Lull W.
Alter!
Wie kann das sein?
Ich copy-paste jetzt einfach sinnloses Zeug.
Guckt, bis es geht.
Chat.
Ihr habt schon verstanden, was ich machen will, oder?
Der Battleship hat es aber nicht verstanden.
Du hast ein grundlegendes Missverständnis,
wie PHP funktioniert.
Okay, also, ernsthaft.
Das läuft hier auf meiner Kiste.
Und hat hier einen
Output auf der Konsole.
Da muss ich doch was selbst in diesen Output reingeben.
Das ist schön, Makario.
Wir freuen uns alle.
Machen.
Mach ein Dump.
Und was?
Dd? Was ist Dd?
Dd?
Das ist so weird.
Das hat noch nicht mal einen Hilfetext.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Was auch immer.
Also, ich bin noch nicht mal in der Lage,
einen Output zu machen
auf der Konsole.
Und ich scheine nicht der Einzige zu sein,
der das Problem hat.
Es gibt einfach kein Konsol-Output-Logging.
Ich meine, immerhin kann ich meine Bilder rotieren.
Krasse, krasse
Kek-W-Rotation.
Das ist schön.
Wenn ich eine .NET-Anwendung starte,
da kommt die auch vom Webserver.
Aber ich kann trotzdem Console-Writeline machen.
Hol dir die Debug bei.
Ja, das kann ich im Browser machen.
Aber warum kann ich nicht
ein stinknormales Console-Writeline machen?
In PHP.
Das ist nicht im Scope,
wie es aussieht.
Gibt es nicht.
In der Logging-PHP,
da bin ich doch gerade schon.
In der Logging-PHP
müsste der Default-Driver
Default-Driver
Hier.
Log-Channel.
Hast du dich eben gerade um 90 Grad rotiert?
Doch.
Ja, sowas wie Debug-Log
gibt es ja da anscheinend nicht, oder?
Oh, tatsächlich.
Was macht das jetzt?
Debug-Log.
Debug.
So, okay.
Wie verwendet man das überhaupt?
Nee, das geht wieder ins Log-File.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich gebe es auf,
wir machen keinen Standard-Output.
Wir machen keinen Standard-Output.
Ja, das geht aber ins Log-File.
Das geht nicht auf die Standard-Out.
So.
Okay, dann lassen wir das jetzt.
Dann verlassen wir.
Wir machen keinen Output mit PHP.
Okay.
Ah, nicht.
So, also haben wir jetzt wenigstens unsere ganzen Features.
Features, das ist überhaupt schon zu nennen.
Chat-GPT.
Nee, fragt mal Chat-GPT.
Ich bin gerade nicht eingeloggt.
Also mehr kann meine Beispiel-Anwendung in .NET auch nicht.
Rotaten und Rotaten mit Parameter.
Okay, nice.
So.
Und wie bundle ich das jetzt?
Oder gar...
Nee, gar nicht.
Ich würde einfach das Ding 1 zu 1 auf den Web-Server hoch...
... auf den Web-Server hochladen.
Und dann würde ich das Ding 1 zu 1 auf den Web-Server hochladen.
Schieben.
Und dann geht es einfach?
Das ist...
Nee.
Error-Log.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das wird auch nicht funktionieren, oder?
Mal ausprobieren.
Error-Log.
Okay.
Was macht das?
Warum gibt es tausend Sachen zum...
Hey!
Easy!
Warum ist das so kompliziert?
Warum findet man das in den ersten paar...
...Google-Dinger nicht?
Gibt es da auch noch irgendein Gegenstück zu?
Hauptsache, Error-Log macht ein Warning.
Da hast du rechts mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Was ist denn das Gegenstück zu Error-Log?
Gibt es auch sowas wie...
...einfach nur Log?
Nee, nee.
Das ist...
Okay, das war wieder was ganz was anderes.
Warn.
Log.
Warning.
Nee.
Es gibt nur Error-Log.
Aber okay, wir kriegen immerhin...
Immerhin kriegen wir Standard-Out schon mal was raus.
Ich bin ja schon mal begeistert, ja?
Oder Debug.
Debug?
Log?
Nee, gibt es auch nicht.
Into a File.
Nee, ich will es nicht.
Okay, das...
Leute, damit gebe ich mich zufrieden.
Damit gebe ich mich zufrieden.
Es ist egal.
Es steht halt ein Warning davor.
Aber Hauptsache, ich kann irgendwas auf Standard-Out loggen.
Wenn auch auf sehr wirre Art und Weise.
Ach, man kann hier sogar den Error-Type...
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Es ist Depp-Deprecated.
Nee.
Wait a minute.
Was ist Deprecated?
Nee, nee, Moment.
Moment, nee.
Das ist Deprecated.
Das hier nicht.
String Message Int Message Type.
Okay, Message Type.
Say where the error should go.
Possible values are...
System Logger...
Mail?
No longer an option?
Nee, nee, das bringt ja nix.
Ich will...
Es ist immer ein Error auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber das ist schon mal...
Okay, wenigstens weiß ich jetzt, wie ich Sachen auf der Kommandozeile logge.
Bin begeistert.
Hi, probier mal...
Trigger Error.
PHP.
Used...
Oh.
Uiuiui.
Okay.
Moment, man kann den Trigger Error ernsthaft was Normales eintragen.
Message.
Cack.
Error Level.
Notice.
Jetzt passiert gar nix.
User Warning.
Ah, Moment.
Äh.
Ach, hier haut er das jetzt raus.
Das haut er jetzt hier in der Error...
In der Error-Fehlermeldung.
Ach so.
Okay.
Ja, nee.
Das will ich ja nicht.
Ich will...
Ich will auf der...
Auf der Konsole loggen.
Aber das ist auch schon mal gut.
Zunächst mal...
Mit Trigger Error kann man quasi hier in dem...
In dem Frontend...
Okay.
Also es gibt...
Es gibt Error-Log.
Fertig.
Mehr gibt's anscheinend nicht.
Error-Log.
Cack.
W.
Sehr schön.
Wunderbar.
Okay, nice.
Ich würd sagen, da haben wir Cack.
W.
As a Service erfolgreich in Laravel umgesetzt.
Ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, was es noch für andere nice Picks...
PHP-Frameworks gibt.
Weil ich hab heute noch nicht genug von PHP.
Ich fand das so geil.
Wir brauchen unbedingt noch mehr PHP-Sachen.
Okay.
Awesome.
PHP.
Jawoll.
Beste.
Frameworks.
Micro-Frameworks.
Laravel Zero.
Nee, das wird ja nicht mal weiterentwickelt.
Oder doch?
Console Applications?
Wait a...
Wer ist denn so masochistisch veranlagt?
Und...
Wer macht Konsolen-Anwendungen mit PHP?
Was?
Hip-Hop?
PHP?
PHP-Code ist translated zu C++.
Also irgendwann nehmen ja die Abscheulichkeiten auch kein Ende mehr, oder?
Was?
PHP?
Jee.
Das Jee-PHP-Framework.
GitHub.
Fast, secure and professional.
Ahmed hat committed.
Auf geht's.
PHP.
PHP-Jee-Framework.
Das ist doch bestimmt von Yahoo oder sowas.
Nee.
Ich will mal kurz gucken.
Was ist denn...
Micro-Framework?
Metz-Radar?
Silly?
Slim?
What the f...
Wie das aussieht, man.
Gekommen jetzt am Start.
Okay, sehr beliebtes Framework.
Massive beliebtes Framework.
Geupdatetes Framework.
Geupdatetes...
Was auch immer.
Alter.
Nee, Cent kenne ich noch von früher.
Das war richtig abartig.
Cake-PHP.
Getting started.
Okay.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Ich glaube, das ist...
Das ist ja auch relativ beliebt, oder?
Oh, jetzt geht's ab.
Leute, Rapid Development in PHP.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt auch noch an.
Wir machen genau die gleiche Anwendung, jetzt noch in Cake.php.
Die Anwendung selber ist ja easy.
Okay, getting started.
Wow, mein Auge.
Installation.
IES, if you prefer.
Gibt es jemanden ernsthaft, der den IES
preferred?
Install Composer, haben wir.
Wir haben Composer.
Composer, create project.
Prefer dist.
Cake.php App.
Ist das die aktuelle
Version?
Nee, 4.
Warum ist das?
Sowas hasse ich immer,
wenn die Anleitungen schon outdated sind.
Oh, Moment.
Please upgrade to, ich hab nichts gesagt.
Die Google-Suche ist einfach
nur pepega.
Okay, ist gut.
Ja, ich hab's gesehen.
Installation.
Using Oven.
Ernsthaft, die machen hier jetzt komplett
ein auf Backen.
Und was heißt, wie heißt denn das
Publish-Command? Bake oder
MKDeer?
Cake.w, as a service.
Cake.
Okay, mal gucken, ob das jetzt ein bisschen
weniger hat. Ich mach mal hier
PHPStorm. Bam.
Trust, wir trusten.
This window.
Okay.
PHP-Cake-Application-Skeleton.
Installation.
Haben wir gemacht.
Haben wir das gemacht?
Ja, haben wir gemacht.
If you want to
customize the
BinCake-Server.
Was?
Hä?
Wait a minute. Was?
You must enable the Intel
extension to use in-home
requirements PHP.
Okay.
Intel.
Und wie mach ich das jetzt?
Geht nicht, wenn du AMD hast.
You must enable the Intel
extension.
Hab ich doch.
Ah, ich hab den Kram nicht installiert.
PHP-Intel.
Wie installier ich denn PHP-Intel?
Auch mit, auch mit Composer?
You can remove this.
Eh, extension is not loaded.
Okay, wie fix ich das?
Man muss, man muss, man muss, man muss, man muss, man muss.
Man muss tatsächlich PHP-Intel installieren.
PHP-Inni?
Okay.
Wow, wow. Was jetzt?
Äh.
Was?
No such online
five? Ist es?
Hä?
Ja, wahrscheinlich fehlt das
Package, das Package.
Aber welches davon ist das
richtige?
Die drei?
Nee.
PHP-56?
Funktioniert alles richtig gut.
Ja.
Install PHP-Intel.
Uptinstall, okay.
Arsch.
Das muss, ich glaub, man muss das wirklich exklusiv in Docker-Container benutzen, sonst kannst du es klicken.
Aber das ist doch schon.
Da steht Provides PHP-Intel.
Das müsste eigentlich schon dabei sein.
Warum kannst du auf der Arbeit nicht googeln?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Gibt es so eine Art Google?
Gibt es so was wie System-CTL-Restart-PHP?
Ich meine, nichts, was da im Hintergrund läuft, aber man weiß ja, man weiß ja nie, ja.
Nee, PHP gibt's nicht.
Ja, aber ist dabei.
Weil alles selbst gebaut ist bei euch.
Wir nutzen nicht mal Git.
Das erscheint mir allerdings nicht sonderlich effektiv zu sein, was da passiert.
Was? PHP-M.
Less Intel.
Ja.
Macht's.
Also, das ist geladen.
Anscheinend.
Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen geht das nicht.
Muss ich das vielleicht...
Muss ich das vielleicht gar nicht hier hinzufügen?
Nee, jetzt ist es nicht drin.
Nice.
Funktioniert ja richtig gut.
Also, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was ich jetzt machen muss, dass das funktioniert.
Paid Opening Required.
kekw-vendor-autoload in...
Was?
Alter, was willst du überhaupt von mir, Mann?
Autoload PHP.
Ach, die gibt's gar nicht.
Wait a minute, die Datei gibt es gar nicht.
What?
Das ist das Demo-Projekt.
Okay, nochmal die Anleitung kurz checken.
Creative hab ich gemacht.
Genau so.
Okay, wir machen das nochmal rückgängig.
rm
Composer, create project.
Würdest du deine C++ oder deine PHP-Erfahrung höher raten?
Was ist das?
Folder permission?
Das hat er mich vorhin nicht gefragt.
Yes.
Äh, meine C++-Erfahrung.
Bin?
Jetzt geht's.
Ich hab keine Ahnung warum, einfach das Projekt nochmal neu gemacht.
Okay, jetzt geht's.
8, 7...
6, 5...
Wow.
Database Driver.
MySQL.
Ich... Leute! Alter!
Was ist das?
Wer hat sich das ausgedacht mit PHP, Mann?
Ich will keine Datenbank haben, defaultmäßig.
Lass mich doch einfach in Ruhe, Mann.
Ich will stinknormal...
Ich will zwei APN-Punkte haben.
Ohne Datenbank, ohne irgendwas, Mann.
Ich brauche nicht RAW-PHP.
Slim. Ja, das habe ich schon gesehen.
Aber was mich an Slim ein bisschen abschreckt...
Ich meine, das hat...
Oh!
Ich habe mich verguckt.
Ich habe eben was gesehen, das hatte 80...
11k Sterne, ja, das ist gut.
Das will ich haben.
Slim.
Slim Framework.
Slim is a PHP Micro Framework that helps you create right, simple yet powerful web applications and APIs.
Ja, das will ich haben, genau.
User Guide.
Getting started.
Installation.
Install Composer.
Install Slim.
Install PSR 7.
Nie holen!
PS...
Was soll ich installieren?
Guzzle PSR 7.
Was ist PSR 7?
Das...
Ein Web Server?
Ist das Absicht, dass er den PHP-Tag nie beendet?
Das macht man so...
Ok.
ok also dann weg damit so jetzt jetzt erst kommt die minimal geschichte composer require slim ist
slim überhaupt das richtige slim github die richtige version 4 ja ok da ist da sind wir
so php storm wir trasten alles klar richtige trust aus am start wenn du gibt nichts so ich
gehe mal davon aus das hat er schon gemacht psr gedöns ich mache jetzt einfach mal das hier weiß
ich genau ist das ein web server ich weiß nicht genau was psr 7 sein soll ok und jetzt machen
wir public index php ok
new folder public index php auf geht's hello world und wie führe ich das jetzt aus einfach
php punkt oder sowas slim ja so how to run the application wäre schon mal ganz spannend also
ok php how to run slim first application walkthrough
das ist noch drei jahre gemacht den public in ex php hier ja so was wäre schon mal ganz schön zu
wissen localhost port 80 80 low resource fond a moment wo sich das ausführen im hab ihr public
hello da sind wir easy sehr schön dass kann man jetzt okay ich glaube hier kann man jetzt auch
ganz normales Console-Log oder sowas machen.
Slim Console-Log.
Log Standard-Bot.
Okay, das ist jetzt hier auch nicht so
einfach, wie man sich das vorstellt. Okay.
Logging scheint in PHP, also Sachen
auf Standard-Out zu schreiben ist nicht im Scope
bei vielen PHP-Sachen anscheinend.
So, okay, weiter.
Das sieht ja relativ
simpel aus, ja.
Okay, get
slash function. So, dann machen wir nochmal was
hier. Get
keg w
function request
response args.
Wunderbar. Ja, das
ist das eine. Jetzt ist natürlich nur
die Preisfrage, wie kriege
ich was hin, was ein
Parameter hat. Slim
api Parameter.
Ne, slim.
Parameters, genau.
Hier, get books
mit Doppelpunkt und dann
function. Aha.
Echo? Okay.
Keck w?
Angle rotation.
Int.
Warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Hä?
Das ging doch eben auch.
Was ist das für eine PHP-Version?
Was? PHP 5.6?
Wir haben 8.2.
Was auch immer das da wieder erkannt hat.
Wir haben 8.2, wir haben nicht
PHP. So, und
jetzt hier response. Okay, das
body write.
Machen wir mal einfach sowas hier.
Ach, ne. Sowas?
Hier dann?
Hoffe ich mal. Aber auto
reload wird es nicht haben.
Keck w?
Äh, ne.
Mh.
Ähm, okay.
Anscheinend macht man so doch keine Routen.
Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht.
Geht dann
das hier mit slash
keck w? Das geht.
Ich hatte die V2
do... Ah, Moment.
Oh, vier. Lull.
Parameter.
Request-Parameter. Ja, ja.
Schon... Hä?
Parameter.
Ja, Mensch, so kompliziert kann es doch nicht sein.
Ich will kein...
Ich will aus der Route
was haben.
Also quasi sowas hier, ja?
Also quasi...
Ich seh da nix. Post.
How to get request.
Object.
Du musst den Body holen und dann...
Alter, warum ist das
so eklig alles?
Ne. Ja.
Sowas.
ID.
Warum ist da so ne random Klammer hinten?
Ach, weil's optional ist.
Okay.
Rotation. Also im Prinzip...
Okay, Moment. Machen wir das nochmal hier.
Sowas will ich haben?
Okay, das funktioniert.
Das funktioniert.
Warum...
Warum kein Laravel?
Haben wir doch ganz am Anfang gemacht.
Response. Okay.
So, und jetzt mit Arcs oder wie?
Arcs?
Warum gibt es nicht einfach jetzt sowas wie Rotation?
Oder so?
Was mach ich jetzt mit Arcs?
Explode. Arcs...
What the fuck?
Was?
Muss ich jetzt so machen?
Dollar, Arcs?
Rotation?
Sowas?
Okay, Moment.
Ich hab ja was gelernt.
Error, Lock, Rotation.
Aber hier geht das...
Ja!
Okay, so geht das.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen umständlich, aber...
Aber okay.
Okay, ja, alles klar.
Ja, das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
So, und jetzt nochmal Image Rotaten.
Das wissen wir ja, wie das geht mit dem Image Rotaten.
Das können wir uns hier...
Raus... Raussaugen.
Ähm...
Oh, wo war das jetzt bei Laravel nochmal drunter?
Roots, ne?
Roots, RP.
Ja.
Oh, ich hab keinen WIM mit Console Support.
Aber das ist auch nicht weiter wild hier.
Image, Make...
Okay, ich brauch jetzt mal Image.
Ich muss den Kram erstmal installieren.
Ich muss den Kram erstmal installieren hier.
Äh, Composer?
Nee, wie ist das Ding?
Intervention.
Okay.
Image.
Ah, Moment.
Falscher Ordner.
Null.
Inter...
Und auch nicht in Public, sondern hier.
Require.
Intervention Image.
Jaja.
Image.
Da sind wir doch.
Jetzt müssen wir das importieren.
Importieren.
Das da ist das Richtige.
Das hab ich jetzt gelernt.
So, und das war's.
Make keg w.png.
So, das Bild hab ich noch nicht.
Das heißt, der wird mir jetzt sagen...
Not fa...
Was?
Moment.
Bis hierhin hat's eben doch noch funktioniert.
Ah, ich bin im falschen Ordner.
Public.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, was jetzt?
Uncaught error.
Das ist ja schlimmer als Java-Fehlermeldung.
Was ist denn das Problem?
Das Bild gibt es nicht, aber wo steht das?
Nee, Class not found.
Class not found.
Okay.
But why?
Das Package ist Laravel-specific.
Nee.
Ist es nicht.
Wie kommst du da drauf?
Wow.
Windows.
Da geh ich bestimmt nicht drauf auf diese Seite da unten, die da unten verlinkt ist.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich komm mir verarscht vor von PHP.
Das ist ja maximal unverständlich.
Also, ich mein, sogar meine IDE erkennt, dass ich es installiert hab.
Aber PHP selber sagt, das gibt es nicht.
Ja gut, mein PHP sucht das auch nicht.
Aber wie, wie, wie würde ich ihm sagen, dass er es sucht?
Okay.
Slim.
Rotate Image.
PHP.
Boah, nee, ey.
Oh, ich hab keinen Bock mehr, Leute.
PHP nervt mich.
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Fertig.
Kein PHP mehr.
Reicht mir.
Kein PHP.
Scheiß drauf.
Snapshot.
Weg.
Weg mit allem PHP, was wir heute gemacht haben.
Zack, bam.
Jetzt Spring Boot.
Jetzt noch.
Ja, war hinten drauf, ja.
Oh, Gott.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich glaube, Spring Boot ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Alles, was ich bisher von gehört hab.
Nicht, dass ich mich jetzt mit Java beschäftigen will.
GRPC mit Go.
Nee, wenn schon, wenn schon.
Die coolen Leute machen ja auch gar kein GRPC mehr.
Die coolen Leute machen T, TRPC oder sowas, wie das heißt, ne.
Das geht aber natürlich nur mit Node.js.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, für ASP.net gibt's da noch nix, ne.
Das ist.
Jetzt Rust.
Nein.
Ich mach jetzt kein Rust.
Ich mach jetzt auch kein Spring Boot.
Ich mach auch kein Python mit Django.
Ich mach auch kein GraphQL oder sonst was.
Heute, heute, heute war PHP.
So.
Und PHP hat mir nicht gefallen.
Das wird's gewesen sein.
Ja, hätten wir das mal alles richtig Agile im Container-Workload deployed, wär alles gut gewesen.
Brainfuck.
Mal kurz die Klimaanlage ausschalten.
Wie kühl.
Boah, das hat mich echt gefreut.
Das hat mich echt genervt jetzt.
Also, ich kann mir vorstellen, wenn man ein bisschen PHP macht, ist es irgendwann erträglich.
Aber wirklich schön.
Chatge, ich hab ja mitbekommen, es sind einige von euch am Start, die PHP machen, ja.
Gibt es jemanden von euch, der PHP wirklich gerne macht?
Oder ihr macht halt einfach nur PHP, weil ihr PHP-Anwendungen betreut?
Macht jemand von euch wirklich gerne PHP?
Man hat so viele wunderbare Sonderheiten.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das ein Vorteil ist.
Okay.
Wir haben ein paar PHP-Enjoyer.
Heute nur noch C-Sharp.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ASP.NET Core ist so ein angenehmes Framework.
Ich wüsste auch gar nicht, warum ich Sachen in PHP machen sollte.
Das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist wirklich, wenn ich das auf irgendeinem Billig-Web-Hosting-Gedöns laufen lassen will.
Andernfalls irgendeine billige VM im Internet kannst du ja alles drauflaufen lassen, was du willst.
Also, insofern, eigentlich gibt es nicht wirklich einen Grund, das in PHP zu machen.
Das war schon echt eklig.
Ja, Cloud Run kannst du ja auch alles laufen lassen.
Du brauchst ja nur ein Container-Image.
Viel E-Commerce läuft mit PHP.
Ja, ich weiß.
Das liegt aber, glaube ich, genau an diesen Gründen.
Du kannst es auf jedem Host da laufen lassen und diese Software ist meistens ja auch schon uralt.
Oder man nimmt sowas als As-a-Service, sowas wie Shopify.
Dann musst du dich mit sowas überhaupt nicht mehr beschäftigen.
Ich reboote mal kurz, dass ganze PHP-Shit weg ist.
Wobei, ne, ich habe meinen Snapshot restored.
Eigentlich muss ich gar nicht rebooten.
Klar, den Snapshot gleich wieder löschen, sonst vergesse ich es.
Übrigens, ich habe gelesen, wir haben uns doch letztens überlegt, ob wir nicht mal testweise bei der Oracle Cloud uns angucken sollten,
...
... ob die kostenlose VM was taugt.
Weil die haben ja immerhin, glaube ich, ne 4-Kerne-VM mit irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 4G-RAM oder so kostenlos.
Und ich habe letztens gelesen, dass Oracle mal ganz gerne einfach Accounts terminiert, ohne einen Grund zu nennen.
Obwohl die das Free-Tier nicht überschreiten.
Also typischer Oracle-Schrott mal wieder.
Der Hintergrund passt nicht so wirklich gut, oder?
Ups, falscher.
Wir haben einen passenden Hintergrund dafür.
Wir haben...
Es gibt ja extra einen für PHP.
Den hier müssten wir jetzt eigentlich nehmen.
Badge PHP.
Hat PHP wirklich so ein Elefant als Maskottchen?
Ich dachte, das ist Postgres mit dem Elefant.
Ach, tatsächlich. Okay.
Postgres Maskottchen?
Ach nee, das sieht anders aus.
Da muss ich sagen, da sieht der PHP-Elefant aber deutlich netter aus.
Der PHP-Elefant erinnert mich ein bisschen an Sendung mit der Maus-Elefant.
So ein bisschen.
Aber der Postgres-Elefant, der stinkt dagegen ab. Der sieht nicht so nice aus.
Slonik heißt der Postgres-Elefant. So, so.
Guck mal, es gibt sogar einen Kappa-Brite PHP-Elefant.
Nice.
Hypergachi.
Immerhin hat PHP den Spaceship-Operator.
Was ist denn der Spaceship-Operator? Das Ding?
Und was macht der Spaceship-Operator?
Wofür ist der Spaceship-Operator da?
Kleiner und größer, aber nicht gleich? Oder wie? Oder...
Null Plan davon.
Habe der es leid.
Wenn ich per Oracle Cloud Free Tier ein eigenes VPN hoste, dürfte man ja von außen bei mir draufkommen, solange ich eine IPA habe.
Ja.
Wenn du brauchst einen IPV4 Endpunkt. Ja, das geht.
Geht aber einfacher. Du brauchst nicht mal einen VPN zu machen. Du kannst doch einfach eine SSH-Verbindung machen mit Port-Weiterleitung.
Brauchst gar keinen VPN.
Machst SSH-Port-Weiterleitung. Brauchst keinen VPN.
Also wenn das alles ist, was du haben willst.
Dann sagst du...
Dann musst du irgendwie sinngemäß sowas sagen. SSH-Port-Weiterleitung.
Ja.
Dann kannst du mir sowas sagen. SSH-G-Remotes-Port 8080 auf 192.168.1.1 slash 80... Irgendwie sowas.
Und dann blub at blub.de.
Was auch immer deine Domain ist.
Falls du eine Domain hast oder irgendwie die externe IP von deiner VM.
So müsste das funktionieren.
Es kann sein, dass du...
Wenn du eine IP hast, dass du SSH-Global-Port-Weiterleitung einschalten musst.
Das geht.
Also das würde dir reichen.
Da brauchst du keinen extra VPN bauen.
Und nachdem du dir eh eine Linux-Kiste holst, ist das wahrscheinlich eine bessere Variante.
Also ich meine, du brauchst ja einen internen Endpunkt auch.
Und sag ich so, der gleiche Server, wo was läuft.
Ja, genau. Das kannst du damit machen.
Machst einen SSH-Tunnel.
Da brauchst du keinen VPN.
Ich meine, du kannst auch einen VPN machen.
Ja, wenn du mehrere Sachen...
Wobei, nee, mehrere Sachen geht nicht.
Du musst ja schon explizit Ports weiterleiten.
Ja, das ist korrekt.
Das ist richtig. Nur TCP-Packages.
Aber das sollte ja das meiste sein.
Ja, aber von der Idee her funktioniert das.
Du brauchst halt einen Public Endpoint und irgendeine Kiste bei dir lokal, wo drauf das läuft.
Und dann musst du halt...
Meine VPN alleine reicht dir ja noch nicht wirklich.
Du musst natürlich gucken, wie du die Ports dann da drüber weiterleitest.
Aber prinzipiell, ja, kann man das damit machen.
Kann man das damit machen, so einen Tunnel bauen.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich einen SSH-Tunnel machen.
Das ist deutlich einfacher.
Und Minecraft Multiplayer ist doch bestimmt TCP-based, oder?
Hat MonkaS in PHP...
Der X7 Airworker, der war auch schon lange nicht mehr da.
Lange nicht gesehen hier.
Minecraft Modgis hat er am Start.
Und ist immer noch voll dabei hier.
Boah, meine Augen!
Äh, GitHub ist immer noch da?
Wie jetzt?
Achso, ja, aber dein Arbeitgeber ist echt komisch drauf, oder?
Also ich mein, du darfst nicht Google benutzen, du darfst nicht GitHub benutzen.
Ihr habt noch nicht mal Git.
Ihr benutzt keine gescheiten IDEs, keine gescheiten Frameworks.
Warum eigentlich?
Was ist das für ein Laden?
Warum?
Heißen die so? Sagt mir nix.
Achso, Piper nutzen wir.
Sagt mir nix.
Ist das PHP?
Ähm...
Naja.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ein Unternehmen, was die Leute nicht ins Internet lässt zum googeln,
erwartet doch nicht, dass die irgendwie gescheite Sachen auf die Reihe bekommen.
Du kannst doch aus dem Kopf nicht alles wissen.
Du musst permanent googeln.
40%, 40, 50% der Zeit ist googeln.
Alles selbst gebaut, kannst nicht nachgoogeln.
Ja, aber zumindest mal wie man in der Sprache...
Ja, hast schon recht, versteh ich.
Ist ja ätzend.
Ey, willkommen in der Steinzeit.
Anscheinend.
Sieht man gerade im Chat, ja.
Es ist echt Steinzeit angesagt bei vielen.
Ja, sucht euch was anderes.
Ernsthaft.
Er arbeitet bei googeln, deswegen darf er googeln nicht benutzen.
Klingt logisch, ja.
Ups, jetzt habe ich glaube ich ein bisschen Wasser verschüttet.
Okay, mal kurz gucken, ob ich irgendwie Lappen habe.
Ja, hier.
Exzellent.
Naja Leute, also, unsere PHP...
Ahem.
Unser PHP-Ausflug war jetzt beschränkt erfolgreich.
Ja, okay.
Ja, es ist aber schon ein bisschen oldschool.
Wenn man noch nicht mal mehr 2023 Git verwenden kann.
Hat sich auch nicht ohne Grund durchgesetzt.
Was ist das?
Von 2016?
What the fuck?
Bist du bei Google?
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass Google so ein Akt macht.
Nee, oder?
Bei Google muss es doch halbwegs angenehm sein, irgendwas zu entwickeln.
Okay, das würde vielleicht erklären, warum YouTube so kaputt ist.
Chrome OS.
Oh, das stelle ich mir tatsächlich ganz angenehm vor.
Ich meine, bei mir auf der Arbeit bin ich dazu gezwungen.
Musst ihr mal vorstellen.
Dass ich Windows benutzen muss.
Und total zugekleistertes Windows.
Du bootest das Ding.
Und hast erst mal 20 Icons in der Taskleiste von Antivirus und sonst was.
Selbstverständlich ist WSL deaktiviert.
Lull, was glaubst du denn?
Aber ich habe es mittlerweile ganz gut hingekriegt.
Ich habe eine Cloud Linux VM.
Oder Linux VM.
Auf der ich Root-Rechte habe.
Und mit der mache ich alles.
Das einzige, was ich auf meinem Notebook laufen habe, ist Fullscreen.
Und das ist das, was ich auf meinem Notebook laufen habe.
Fullscreen.
Fullscreen Terminal.
Fertig.
Ne, das Visual Studio Code Terminal.
Ja gut, kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Wenn man wirklich alles ins gleiche Repo schmeißt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da auch noch viele Binaries und sowas drin sind.
Dann wird es natürlich.
Und vor allem, wenn sich dann auch noch an diesen Sachen öfters was ändert.
Dann wird das mit Git schwierig.
Bei uns auch so.
Ich habe.
Ja.
Wie gesagt.
Also ich würde.
Ich würde Anfälle kriegen.
Wenn ich die Windows Kiste wirklich benutzen müsste.
Um was drauf zu machen.
So als reines Ding, wo ein Terminal drauf läuft.
Ist es okay.
Ich meckere auch schon.
Ich habe auch letzte Teamrunde wieder gemeckert.
Ich habe gesagt, Leute.
Überlegt euch.
Ich kenne übrigens auch einige Entwickler bei uns.
Die das sagen, dass sie gerne Linux hätten.
Und.
Bisher interessiert es da keinen.
Aber ich werde weiter nerven.
Ich werde das bei jeder Gelegenheit.
Wenn es Probleme gibt.
Oder es zu kompliziert ist.
Werde ich ein bisschen Windows flamen.
Und sagen, ja.
Würde ich halt mal Linux kriegen.
Wer das entscheidet.
Ja.
Das ist glaube ich schwierig zu sagen.
Also mein Chef alleine entscheidet es definitiv nicht.
Also schon mal gar nicht für die Entwickler.
Das ist eher so eine Policy Sache bei uns.
Dass irgendjemand sich die Mühe machen muss.
Und das quasi offiziell beantragen.
Und dann.
Ey Leute.
Bei uns Linux Workstations zu unterstützen.
Das ist eine Lebensaufgabe.
Nicht auf meinem offiziell gestellten Notebook.
Ich arbeite schon den ganzen Tag.
Auf Linux.
Aber das Notebook was ich gestellt bekomme.
Ist Windows.
Ja.
Natürlich.
Auf Linux könnte ich mir beispielsweise.
Einfach aus dem Package Manager.
Das installieren was ich brauche.
Was ich bei mir auf dem Notebook nicht machen kann.
Aber auf meiner VM.
Glücklicherweise.
Aber ist Docker drauf?
Nö.
Da ist nichts drauf.
Sinnvolles.
Auf der.
Auf der Windows Kiste.
Ich benutze die Windows Kiste.
Rein als Terminal.
Für.
Meine.
Meine Linux VM.
Ich habe eine Linux VM.
Auf der habe ich Root Rechte.
Und.
Ich habe dann Terminal im Fullscreen auf.
Und connect mich da drauf.
Fertig.
Das ist übrigens auch immer so ein Punkt.
Wenn manche in ihre Stellenanzeigen reinschreiben würden.
Freie Betriebssystem Auswahl.
Wenn sie sowas haben.
Ist auch für einige Leute.
Ein großer Pluspunkt.
Also ich fände das auf jeden Fall gut.
Wenn man das gleich.
Wenn man damit wirbt.
Weil das für mich heißt.
Okay.
Wenn ich jetzt.
in der Live-Umgebung einzuloggen und dort die Festplatten
zu löschen, kann ja auch nicht passieren.
Also wenn es einer wirklich mutwillig
was zerstören will, dann bestimmt
nicht mit einem Linux, geht das
dir nicht nur mit einem Linux-Notebook.
Ja, ist auch so, ist auch so.
Ist auch so, also sprich, das muss
dann alles ganz genau
dokumentiert sein, warum das
warum, wie, was verwendet wird. Die haben sich
sogar schon aufgeregt, ihr müsst euch das mal vorstellen.
Kubernetes Helm
Install, da kam dann jemand um die
Ecke und hat gemeint, was ist denn das für eine Software?
Die ist aber nicht freigegeben.
Da wollten die ernsthaft
erzählen, die Leute dürfen nichts mit Helm installieren,
weil Helm nicht freigegeben ist.
Das ist wirklich,
also was das angeht, ist der Laden echt
hyper-pepeger, Alter.
Ja, naja, komm, bei LS
bei LS hast du doch schon mal kein Rollback-Verfahren.
Wie ist das Rollback-Verfahren bei
LS? Ganz
furchtbar gefährliche Software.
Also, in meinem
letzten Vorstellungsgespräch
wurde ich auch ein paar
so typische Personal-Dinger gefragt.
So, was müssten wir machen, um sie so richtig
zu ärgern und sowas?
Wo sehen sie sich
in fünf Jahren?
Das war aber lustig.
Das war aber lustig, wo der
der hat irgendwie
gemeint, ja, und so eine Frage, die er immer
fragt und da hab ich zu ihm gesagt, so
lassen sie mich
ran, wo sehen sie sich in fünf
Jahren? Leute, ja, genau.
Nein, bitte nicht, die 0815-Frage
schlechthin.
Haben wir mal drüber gekeckt, eine Runde
und dann war auch gut.
Was sind ihre Schwächen? Naja,
ehrlich,
so richtig ehrlich antworten in einem
Vorstellungsgespräch
ist halt immer so eine Sache,
ja, wenn du sagst, meine Schwäche
sind Leute, die dumme Fragen stellen,
das kannst du ja in der Situation
nicht machen, dann denk dir irgendwas aus,
was eigentlich für dich, also was für dich
eigentlich eher einen,
was eigentlich eher nach Vorteil
aussieht, du kannst, du könntest zum
Beispiel sowas sagen, wie, ja,
wenn ich, wenn ich erstmal angefangen hab, mich
mit irgendeinem Problem auseinanderzusetzen,
dann, dann lass ich mich
gar nicht mehr davon abbringen und
was auch immer, denk dir irgendwie so einen Blödsinn aus.
Ja.
Also ich, ich würde wahrscheinlich sagen,
ähm,
ich hab,
ich hab, ähm, also das ist ja aber auch
wahr, deswegen ist das so eigentlich eine ganz gute
Antwort, ähm, ich hab,
ich hab so eine Schwäche, was das angeht, und zwar
ich hab meistens relativ genaue
Vorstellungen, wie ich was
ordentlich finde, beziehungsweise wie ich
denke, dass das die richtige Art und Weise
ist, wie was betrieben werden soll
und ich lass mich da auch
immer schwer von abbringen, ja.
Solche Fragen dienen oftmals gar nicht so
sehr dem eigentlichen Erkenntnisgewinn,
was sagt er denn, sondern eher so,
ähm, wie, wie reagiert
er denn auf so ein bisschen schwierige
Frage, aber
das, das ist immer, ist es immer,
cringe, so, ein wenig, ja.
Ich hatte letztens ein Vorstellungsgespräch
und die Technik, welche Programmiersprache
nutzen Sie in Ihrem Beruf? Ja, Moment,
das, der hätte ich, das sagt
ihr mir das doch, was mach ich denn hier?
Laut ihrer, laut ihrer
Stellenanzeige suchen Sie Leute, die, keine Ahnung,
Java und Dings und sonst was
können, ähm,
was, was suchen
Sie denn so? Nicht das, oder wie?
Oh.
BWL
fragen, das klingt,
auch schon, ja.
Das ist nicht nur
in deutschen Unternehmen so,
das ist international teilweise noch krasser,
was die da für blödes Zeug fragen.
Oder, oder wenn du Pech hast, musst
du dich auch an die Tafel stellen und
dann, ähm,
den Bein retreieren,
zu den Klassikern.
Ja gut, das, das hab ich ja
auch gesagt, das, also das,
das hab ich tatsächlich so, das
hab ich tatsächlich so gesagt, allerdings
nicht auf diese Frage, sondern ich
wurde im Vorstellungsgespräch gefragt,
was müssten, was müssten wir
machen, um sie so richtig zu ärgern?
Da hab ich gesagt, Windows administrieren.
Interessant, ja, schick die
schnell, aber hier, Moment, bevor du die,
bevor du die schickst, überleg dir das nicht,
dass sie das zufälligerweise sehen, wenn, wenn
wir hier ein bisschen flamen über die, aber sonst
schick, schick mal rüber, ich guck mir das an.
Wir haben, wir haben noch, wir haben noch 20 Minuten
Zeit, das passt schon.
Ich musste für mein Vorstellungsgespräch für die Ausbildung
sogar was Kleines programmieren.
Okay, krass, hups.
Was musstest du denn programmieren für
einen, für einen FISI?
Ausbildungs-, Ausbildungsbetrieb, äh,
Ausbildungsberuf für deine,
das kann ja nur was Kleines gewesen, oder?
Man fiel über großartig, Hello World, kann das
ja nicht rausgehen. Man, man muss ja
eigentlich, also man muss
von, wie soll ich das sagen, also von Azubis
würde ich jetzt eigentlich nicht erwarten, dass
die schon super krasse
Vorkenntnisse haben. Ich mein, wenn's einer hat,
könnte ich mir's vielleicht durchaus auch mal vorstellen, das mit
demonstrieren zu lassen, gerade wenn er damit
groß angibt, aber ansonsten,
wär das für mich nicht so.
Ja, okay, das ist ja easy.
Hatte ich nicht, gab's nicht.
Würde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr machen.
Die, die, ey, Leute, ich hatte
ein Drei-Stunden-Vorstellungsgespräch.
Das hat sich wirklich
echt hingezogen, aber es war gut,
weil, gut,
mein, die erste Sache war eigentlich, wir sind die geilste
Firma auf der Welt und was haben sie bisher
so gemacht und bla bla bla.
Dann ging's so ein bisschen, so diese Sachen mit
Stärken und Schwächen und
typisches, typisches Vorstellungsgespräch-Talk.
Und am Ende ging's drum, dass wir uns einig
sind und dann, was ich an Kohle haben will.
Und dann waren wir uns einig und sie haben gleich
gesagt, wir schicken wir schon vorläufigen Vertrag,
ja, drei Stunden.
Oder knapp drei Stunden ging das.
Es war eigentlich nur auf, nur auf zwei
angesetzt, aber
ging drei.
Weil eigentlich haben wir uns am Anfang
darüber, darauf verständigt, wir können heute
ja eh noch nix genau entscheiden.
Was ich auch persönlich gut fand, weil ich hatte ja
schon einen anderen Vertrag vorliegen.
Und ohne,
ohne Pause, non-stop.
Aber es war halt auch so,
weil wir nicht fertig geworden sind, da war ich auch ein bisschen
mit dran schuld, ne. Ich mein, ich hab ja auch ein paar Sachen
gefragt und wollte noch ein bisschen erzählen und so.
War eigentlich gar nicht schlecht.
Und
normalerweise hatten wir uns
eigentlich drauf geeinigt, wir entscheiden uns heute noch
nicht. Wir wollen danach, jede, jede Seite will
danach nochmal kurz überlegen. Aber wir haben uns dann
so gut verstanden nach zwei Stunden,
dass wir gesagt haben,
weißt du was, wir machen das gleich
und dann mussten wir uns halt auch noch kurz überlegen.
Und dann mussten wir uns auch noch um Gehalt und alles unterhalten.
Normalerweise hätte man das bei einer zweiten Runde gemacht,
aber wir haben das alles in einer Runde gemacht.
Und dann hatte ich, dann hatte ich den Vertrag in der Post
paar Tage später. Das ging wirklich sehr schnell.
Halt alles noch vorläufig.
Weil es musste ja auch schnell gehen,
weil wie gesagt, ich musste ja den anderen,
den anderen, die mir schon,
den ich eigentlich schon quasi zugesagt hatte, wo ich den
Vertrag schon hier auf dem Tisch liegen hatte,
den musste ich ja noch absagen. Leute, das war mir
echt peinlich. Ihr, ihr, ihr könntet,
ihr könntet wahrscheinlich sagen,
ähm, muss einem nicht
peinlich sein, aber, naja,
mir, mir war es ein bisschen peinlich.
Es war eine blöde Situation, ja.
Mit den anderen hatte ich schon zwei Vorstellungsgespräche
geführt. Wir haben uns, haben uns gut verstanden. Die haben mir
schon einen Vertrag geschickt. Wir waren uns
mit allem einig. Und da musste
ich dann da halt anrufen und sagen, ja,
hat sich doch was anderes ergeben.
Ich stehe nicht mehr zur Verfügung.
Und ich hab mich dann übrigens gedrückt davor.
Ich hab dann dort angerufen.
Da war die, die, die Frau
von der Personalabteilung, mit der
ich die ganze Zeit
zu tun hatte, war gerade nicht
da. Und da hab ich dort angerufen, hab mit
jemand anderem geredet und ob er das nicht
ausrichten kann, hat er ausgerichtet und dann war gut.
Und danach
hab ich noch schriftlich abgesagt.
Per Mail. Ja, war
schon ein bisschen unangenehm, ja.
Aber letztendlich,
was willst du machen? Das andere Angebot
war einfach besser. Einfach
ghosten, ja. Ne, das ist, das
ist nix. Das würde ich nicht machen.
Okay, also, zeigt mal her.
Anwendungsentwickler
Betriebsführungssysteme.
Oh, das klingt so ein bisschen nach, nach
Bahn oder sowas.
Sie möchten sich verändern und weiterentwickeln.
Ne, ich will einfach nur Geld verdienen.
Diese Fragen immer am Anfang
von solchen Stellenanzeigen.
Ich will nicht unter der Brücke schlafen, ich brauch Geld.
Sie möchten sich verändern oder
und weiterentwickeln. Nun kann,
dann kann diese Position genau das
Richtige für sie sein. Für die
Lausitz Energie Bergbau AG suchen wir
zwei Anwendungsentwickler.
Betriebsführungssysteme
MWD
Männlich-Weiß-Deutsch, wie immer.
Für den Bereich IT
und Geschäftsprozesse.
Ja, das finde ich aber assi.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Unsere Mitarbeiter sind unser
wertvollstes Kapital.
Wir suchen eine
Soll mich das jetzt irgendwie davon
überzeugen, dass sie
Wir suchen eine motivierte Unterstützung
für unser Team. Die Leute, die
sowas schreiben, das sind halt einfach so Floskeln.
Ich glaube, die denken sich da überhaupt nichts bei.
Wir suchen eine motivierende Unterstützung für unser Team mit Gestaltungswillen.
Wir bieten verantwortungsvolle Aufgaben in einem modernen, respektvollen, in einem
modernen, respektvollen Arbeitsumfeld und hervorragende Weiterbildungsmaßnahmen.
Dabei ist uns auch das Thema Work-Life-Balance sehr wichtig.
Mobiles Arbeiten ist möglich. Das ist schon mal gut.
Mobiles Arbeiten ist möglich, heißt auch Homeoffice ist möglich.
Das ist nur die Frage, in welchem
Als Anmeldung sind wir DWW.
Moment, wie?
Keine Männer?
Ich fühle mich ausgegrenzt.
Spielen sie eine wichtige Rolle
bei der Unterstützung der Geschäftsprozesse?
Bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla
Okay, der Schwerpunkt liegt
auf der Beratung unserer Fachabteilung
zum Einsatz von Ertietungen
bei der Durchführung von Entwicklungsaufgaben
sowie auf der Gesamtverantwortung
Moment,
was?
Du bist Anwendungsentwickler.
Bist du Berater?
Du bist Berater?
Du bist Entwickler?
Und du machst den Betrieb auch noch?
Oder wie?
Oder was?
Oder?
What?
Weitere Aufgaben?
Aber das reicht noch nicht.
Weitere Aufgaben werden sein.
Beraten der Fachabteilung mit Fokus auf den Geschäftsprozessen?
Was?
Du bist Anwendungsentwickler?
Hä?
Okay, den Zusammenhang kann ich jetzt nicht.
Kann ich jetzt nicht herstellen, ehrlich gesagt.
Was die Stellenanzeige mit diesem Aufgabengebiet zu tun hat.
Erfassung und Dokumentieren von Anforderungen,
Erstellen von Lasten und Pflichten.
Naja, okay.
Naja.
Durchführbarkeitsanalysen, Aufwandschätzung für Umsetzung.
Ja, okay.
Aber sollte die Hauptaufgabe eines Anwendungsentwicklers
nicht tatsächlich sein, Sachen zu entwickeln?
Steuern von Entwicklern?
Bist du jetzt auch noch Teamleiter oder wie dabei?
Durchführung von...
Ja, das ist so die Hauptaufgabe eigentlich.
Second-Level-Support für Anwenderübernahme der ITSM-Rolle Systemmanager.
Sind die noch bei Trost oder was?
Wissens- und Know-How-Management?
Leiten von kleinen und mittleren Projekten?
Was zum Teufel ist das für eine Anzeige?
Wer auch immer die geschickt hat, bist du dir wirklich sicher, dass du dahin willst?
Ich meine, es sei denn, die bezahlen wirklich viel.
Die müssen schon mal 100k Plus.
Applikations-spezifische Zuarbeiten an zentralen IT-Projekten.
Ihr Profil als Anwender.
Blablabla.
Ihre Kenntnisse verschiedener Webtechnologien,
Erfahrung mit ITIL-Prozessen im Projektmanagement...
Was zum Teufel?
Du, Chaotix, das kann tatsächlich deutlich besser sein, als die Stellenanzeige jetzt aussieht.
Die Stellenanzeige ist echt kompletter Shit, aber das muss nicht wirklich auf das Unternehmen zutreffen, weil du hast, wir wissen jetzt nicht, wie diese Stellenanzeige entstanden ist, ja, aber ich meine, die Fragen sollten aber im Vorstellungsgespräch schon gestattet sein, so wie das denn alles zu einem Anwendungsentwicklerjob passt.
Also, was die jetzt eigentlich genau von dir wollen, weil die Anforderungen hier sind halt nicht so sehr Entwickleranforderungen und ist ja auch sehr breit gefächert und wir, ja, das würde ich alles ein bisschen netter formulieren, aber das sollten sie schon mal erklären im Vorfeld.
Ich glaube auch, die Personalabteilung, die das geschrieben hat, hat einfach keinen Plan, was sie da schreibt.
Sehr gute Programmierkenntnisse und mehrjährige Erfahrungen, zum Beispiel C Sharp.net, Java, HTML, CSS.
Und relationalen Datenbanken, Oracle, SQL, MySQL, nee, MSSQL, ja, also ich würde es mir an deiner Stelle trotzdem mal anhören, wenn es bei dir in der Gegend nicht so viele Alternativen gibt, aber es ist schon, also die Stellenanzeige ist wirklich mies.
Zusammenarbeit, Teamarbeit, ja gut, Bereitschaft zum Lernen, Übernahme, Verantwortung, Kommunikation, Verständnis von, Verständnis von kaufmännischen und produktionsnahen Prozessen, das ist englisch ausgeprägter.
Analysefähigkeit, hohes Maß an Planung, also die Stellenanzeige ist wirklich Müll, ganz ehrlich.
Was nicht heißt, dass das Unternehmen Müll ist, aber die Stellenanzeige ist Müll.
Moment, das soll auch noch für Berufs...
Moment, Moment, ist das, Chaotix, ist das eine Einstiegsstelle?
Also das kann nicht in den Ernst sein, oder?
Wie viel Erfahrung hast du schon?
Und, also mit wie vielen Jahren bewirbst du dich?
Da, mehrjährige Erfahrung mit dem Schwerpunkt Anwendungsentwicklung und Prozesse, ja gut, du hast 3 Jahre, also ganz ehrlich, ziemliche Pepega-Anzeige.
Haben wir ihr Interesse geweckt? Ehrlich gesagt nicht, nein.
Also die Anzeige ist wirklich äußerst Pepega.
Ghosting, wenn Bewerber kommentarlos aus dem Bewerbungsprozess aussteigen, ja.
Früher haben es Unternehmen gemacht, das rächt sich nun, ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich hab die nicht geghostet.
Ich hab einfach abgesagt, ich find das auch blödsinnig, also ganz ehrlich, das will ich nicht, dass das bei mir im Bewerbungsprozess gemacht wird, so nach dem Motto, wir melden uns nie wieder und ich find das auch nicht fair.
Gerade wenn es, also sollte das ein Kackladen sein, ja, dann kann man sich das überlegen, aber die waren ja nicht schlecht, sonst hätte ich ja gar nicht dran gedacht, da eigentlich anzufangen, also dann ghoste ich die auch nicht, sondern sag halt einfach ab.
Ja, aber das ist doch egal, die haben ihn doch eingeladen.
Das hat er, das, sie geht doch aus seinem Lebenslauf hervor und sie haben ihn trotzdem eingeladen.
Allein schon deswegen kann man sagen, ja, okay, aber ich sitz ja hier.
Wie üblich ist Second Level Support für Anwendungsentwickler selten?
Also, zumindest was ich von unseren Entwicklern jetzt mitbekomme und in der alten Firma mitbekommen hab, also in der alten Firma sogar noch weniger, aber Second Level Support, dass du als Anwendungsentwickler wirklich, wirklich Kontakt hast mit irgendwelchen Endanwendern, äußerst.
Ja, ich mein, das ist doch einfach nicht so.
Hätte ich auch überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, die wollen, die wollen es anscheinend aber auch nicht anders, oder?
Also, ich mein, da muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn die Leute dann schon was Neues haben.
Warum sagst du denen nicht einfach ab?
Jetzt ernsthaft, warum sagst du denen nicht einfach ab?
Hat das einen Grund?
Also, ich will, ich will dich nicht, ich will es dir, ich will es dir nicht ausreden.
Du kannst machen, was du willst.
Auch wenn ich es nicht, nicht so nice finde von dir, aber ich mein, hast ja vielleicht deine Gründe.
Also, warum?
Warum sagst du denen nicht einfach ab?
Hat es einen Grund?
grund kann kann sein weil sie jetzt nicht mal magst trinken ja ich habe ich
habe relativ viel gesoffen hier schon dabei ich habe die ganze wasserflasche
leer getrunken während dem stream normalerweise sollte dann ein
ordentlicher fehler fehlerbericht aufgemacht werden und die hotline
sollte schon irgendwas erstellen in der richtung dass das ist nicht oft vorkommt
dass man als entwickler direkt mit anwendern telefonieren muss ja gut wenn
die wenn die frech wenn die frech schreiben so nach dem motto also du hast
die haben interesse an dir aber du hast absolut kein bock da hinzugehen verstehe
ich richtig na ja kann man so machen ich würde ihn einfach absagen ja kann
sagen du verfolgst jetzt andere andere was auch immer irgendwie lasst ihr chat
gpt eine absage generieren ist doch heute kein ding das stimmt aber in
zeiten von home office und remote arbeit hast du durchaus auch chancen woanders
zu
arbeiten als du wohnst muss so nicht also es gibt ja durchaus unternehmen die
lassen sich auf remote arbeit ein muss doch nicht mal zwangsläufig deutsches
unternehmen sein aber gibt es auch da ein paar manche sagen auch okay
hauptsächlich remote arbeit aber einmal im monat sollte das gesamte team vor ort
sein das kann man sich ja dann tatsächlich
überlegen weil einmal im monat kann man ja durchaus mal zwei stunden zu kind
zwei stunden zurückfahren oder sowas
vielleicht sogar einmal übernachten je nachdem was es ist wenn sich halt lohnt
das muss sich unter dem strich lohnen aber man hat heute hat viel mehr
möglichkeiten dank remote arbeit und home office
ja dann würde ich einfach vier stunden zu fahren das würde ich nicht machen
wirklich einfach sagen und schüss aber in dem vorstellungsgespräch sieht es
schon also bei der bewerbung sieht das doch schon mal ganz anders aus die suchen
ja explizit leute dann oder wenn du dich dafür hast suchst du dir explizit welche
wo im remote arbeit möglich home office mit der datei wir reden jetzt in der
Da redet man ja im Vorfeld schon drüber, wenn man sagt, ich wohne da und da.
Ich habe mich jetzt hier beworben und ihr sucht ja auch Leute mit Remote.
Wenn man sich dann einig ist, dann ist doch klar, wie da die Verhältnisse sind.
Und wenn dann einer ankommt mit, ah, du musst jetzt doch jeden Tag ins Büro, dann ist man wieder weg.
Ja, Steuern bezahlen kommst du nicht drumherum.
Leider.
Naja.
Das ist aber schwer, das ist schwer zu halten.
Ich meine, ich habe wirklich einen super Arbeitsweg.
Ja, ich wohne hier schräg gegenüber vom Bahnhof quasi und muss einsteigen.
Also bei mir ist es sogar aber auch über eine halbe Stunde.
Wenn ich wirklich mal dann auch das Laufen vom Hauptbahnhof zum Büro und so mit einbeziehe,
dann würde ich sagen, bin ich auch eher so 40 Minuten einfach unterwegs.
Und meine Strecke ist wirklich easy.
Und das ist auch nur, wenn die Bahn mitspielt.
Also halbe Stunde ist wirklich sehr knapp bemessen.
Das ist aber auch nicht wild, weil ich arbeite halt, also ich arbeite eh nur vier Tage die Woche
und von den vier Tagen, die ich hier arbeite, ist es auch nur eine halbe Stunde.
Und von den vier Tagen mache ich drei Tage Homeoffice.
Und einen Tag die Woche muss ich nach Frankfurt.
Also easy.
Da kann ich das ohne Probleme auf mich nehmen, da mal ein bisschen unterwegs zu sein.
Weiß nicht, ob das so ein guter Fall ist, bei der Bahn zu arbeiten.
Okay Leute, ich gehe jetzt ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns morgen. Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
See you.